Her low freak bitches.
So at any rate,
there's a story in there
where he talks about, uh,
talking to this person who's like,
uh,
he lived in an all white town except one
of the Klansmen that was d hooded talks
about,
he lived in this all white town and he
was raised very racist and that black
people were the worst.
And there was one black family,
like the Johnson's or whatever.
And his father told him,
all black people are the worst.
They're monkeys.
They're the worst except the Johnsons.
The Johnson's are good,
they're good people.
And he had this realization is like
tickle in his brain of like, wait,
my father hates all the black people
except the black family that he's met.
Like all black people are bad except
the one group that he's actually met.
And that is like the phenomenon
of othering, right? It's like, oh,
black people are bad, Muslims are bad.
But actually my friend Tom, the Muslim,
he's Nice but Muslims wanna kill me.
But the Tom over here,
he's a good dude.
Anyway,
I think other things like the big
one of the big problems that we have,
well it's also I think what's
going on with black lives matter.
One of the things that's going on is
that they're in the middle of the battle,
right?
So right in the middle of the battle,
every day you wake up prime for battle,
getting online, you're active, you're,
you're, you're, you're activating
your membership, your, you know,
organizing,
doing whatever.
And then this guy comes along and he's
doing something totally different.
He's out there talking to the clients
when you go fuck those people, man. Right?
Totally. Yeah. I was for my show that, uh,
that I'm doing my comedy
central show we're doing,
like we just did a cultural appropriation
episode and I was, uh, studying.
So I was studying, I was like deep
in the cultural appropriation.
I was reading so much shit about it.
But one of the more interesting things
that said about black lives matter,
it's kind of connected to this,
is that one thing that happens
with cultural appropriation
and things in general
is that people seize on language. We're
in like a crazy language war right now,
right? Like so many of the
phrases that we use, uh,
are so charged with secondary and
tertiary, meaning that we can't,
they didn't even mean anything anymore.
Like white privilege is a concept
that the moment you bring it up,
there's so many levels of
eye roll that it's like,
I don't even think it's a useful phrase
anymore cause it's like the moment you
say white privilege than a person,
the white person who you're saying
it's privileged is going like fuck you.
And the minute someone saying fuck you,
you, the conversation has ended it. Yeah.
So the thing they said about black lives
matter was also a lot of silly people
use that expression. No doubt.
That's the weird baggage that it has.
Like it's the thing that we learned
about that I learned about cultural
appropriation because for me,
I,
I roll my eyes so deeply at the concept
of cultural appropriation, right?
It's like, oh, so I shouldn't eat burritos
anymore. Is that what you're also,
I always think I'm always really tickled
with the idea of like the person saying,
oh,
you shouldn't wear that tribal gear.
And then it's like go to the third world
country where the market is and tell
the the like impoverished
Pa, uh, in merchant like, oh,
I'm sorry I can't buy this bit of silk
from you because it's racist for me to
wear it. That person. Like please,
please buy it and wear it. Like,
or you know what I'm saying? Or
like the family, it's like, oh,
it would be a great honor if you would
wear this, sorry, or whatever. Right.
So it's a big eye roll. Except then you
start to think like upon reading it,
it's like, oh, the thing is it's
not incidental, it's emotional.
It's like deeper than, than just like
trying to parse out the logic and go,
oh well I found an example
where your thing falls apart.
It's like it's emotional.
There's an emotional reaction.
Like when, when somebody,
you know, affects, you know, dreads up
their hair, even though you can say,
but people have been dreading their hair
in other cultures for a million years,
vikings had dreads and that is true.
It doesn't matter because the
person that's in front of you,
that's a black person that's going,
I have pain when I'm,
I have this pain that I'm looking at,
you know,
a person that's affecting my culture
without any of the negative parts. Right?
So you can, you can wear the hair and
you can have the dreads that, okay.
Just because of the word culture. Because
if that's the case with someone else,
some someone else wearing something
that you might find a fit.
Like what if you're a
person that's extremely, uh,
conservative when it comes to dress and
you see a woman in a short skirt and you
have pain, should that impose upon that
woman's ability to wear that skirt? No,
definitely.
And I'm not making a case that anybody's
pain ought to be automatically, uh,
adopted as like a behavioral standard.
Right? That's not really what I,
I learned that from this
whole discussion is it's like,
it's not really about going.
No one is really saying except
the most emotionally kind of, uh,
in fury.
Like the person that doesn't have the
language to express what they're really
saying.
Almost no one that I read when I was think
reading these real like intellectuals
and their concepts of cultural
appropriation is saying
white people should stop
doing this stuff altogether.
Almost no one,
I didn't find one left wing Wolke article
that said white people should stop
adopting the culture of other,
of people of color. Right.
Okay. I read a lot of right wing think
pieces that were saying this is absurd.
Why are you telling us to
stop adopting these cultures?
Isn't all cultural melting pot
and all cultural borrowing.
But not once did I read somebody saying
white people stop this altogether.
Well what did you read? So, so mostly,
and I hope I can articulate
this well cause I'm,
I'm not the best advocate for this
position because like I said, it's, it's,
it's one that I struggle with that's
dubious. It's dubious and difficult.
And there are ridiculous parts of
the cultural appropriation argument,
but one thing that like it's all
connected to historical trauma.
It's all deeper.
Like basically,
let's see if I can articulate this well
what this one, um, this one person,
and I wish I could find his name actually,
but uh,
because he deserves it because he's
really deep thinker about this stuff was
talking about was that,
you know, we have racism.
Racism is a huge word that that describes
everything from a white person like
hugging their purse closer to their chest
when a black person walks by or even
like a weird, like, you know,
just the smallest little racial weirdness
all the way to lighting across on
somebody's,
on somebody's lawn to murdering someone.
Like that's all encompassed in racism.
So they started trying to like
parse it out. People are going,
when you call someone a racist,
right? They go, I'm not a racist.
You're calling me a monster. And
then somebody will go, oh no,
I meant like a systemically racist.
It's like you need more specific examples.
So cultural appropriation is one, white
privilege is another. There's all these,
but still go back to cope. What,
what cultural appropriation,
like you said that no one was
saying don't do it. Right. So what,
so what are they doing when they're
trying to chop someone's dreads off? Okay.
I don't know about this.
I mean what,
what exactly you mean the San Francisco
state example where the girl attacked
the guy? I mean that girl was just
inarticulately expressing some insanity.
I don't,
I don't think that's defensible and I,
and I think most of the articles and the
stuff that I read about that specific
instance or just like basically saying
that woman's, uh, an uh, a lunatic. Well,
I've heard people though enforce it
and I know someone who was mad at their
friend is a black girls matter. Her friend
who was a white girl who had braids,
she had like corn rows and she was mad
because she was saying that it's cultural
appropriation, cultural appropriation. I
said, if you do, you know about Bo Derek,
right? Like she was one of the first
people to ever have core the Romans,
you know, there's corn rows on
Roman coins actually, right? I mean,
it's crazy thing to call
that cultural appropriation,
but also saying that a white
person shouldn't wear that.
That's fucking crazy because what do you,
what about a black guy wearing a
polo shirt? Well, okay, so, okay.
There's a good example, right?
Yeah. Is, uh, and again,
I'm not like I'm not the greatest
advocate for this position.
I just read so much that made
me empathize with the position.
Not necessarily agree with it,
but empathize with where it's coming from.
So the Polo for example, when you see you
as a white dude or me as a white dude,
when I see somebody wearing a polo,
it's just a polo.
It has no historical antecedent,
it has no historical baggage to it and
there's no connection to systemic racism
or, or Elvis Presley stealing the cream
of the intellectual musical crop and then
never giving back to that
community or Iggy Azalea coming in,
adopting a black accent and then just
like taking all the money and running,
you know, it has no connection to deeper
root systems like these trees have the
communicate with each other, like tastes
bitter. Right? So all it is is a polo.
It's just a guy wearing a polo.
It's,
and that's why the counterargument doesn't
make sense because it's like nobody's
upset when they see a black
dude and a polo shirt. Uh,
I mean maybe some weird racist guy is,
is, but mostly not. On the other hand,
when a person sees
a white person affecting a deep part of
black culture without any of the baggage
that is associated with it,
like for example, dreads, right?
One of the arguments I read a lot is
that like white people wearing braids and
dreads, you know, you get
rewarded for it. You look cool,
you look and meanwhile black women are
having a difficult time getting a job
because they have black hair or black
people getting fired from jobs because
they have dreads.
Right?
So there's these consequences that black
people experience because of black shit
that white people that are adopting
it don't necessarily experience.
That's true at all.
I think if you were working in an
office and some white dude at dreads,
he'd be highly suspicious of
his behavior. Well, for example,
this guy has kind of like get dork.
I hear what you're saying.
I'm going to hire him.
There's a guy that had hair
like you and right next to him,
some stinky white dude with them.
Stinky dreads. Has dreads. Stink. Okay.
Dreads out. Let's say. Well, that's a good
example. Okay. There in the u s military,
there was just a, a new, um,
a new set of acceptable hairstyles and Mo,
almost every one of the unacceptable
hairstyles that they, that they,
that they put into place.
It was basically black hair.
Like what braids? Wearing your hair
natural? Um, I don't know the intro.
What do you mean? I mean, I would have
to, we'd have to be like an Afro. Yeah,
a short, short afro. Yeah. I mean,
you're not allowed to do that.
You'd have to pull up the article
to give the specific examples,
but basically there are a
million different examples
like that. And like I said,
I'm not, I'm not necessarily
an advocate for hed and,
and honor the call of the
appropriation accuser.
I'm more like now realizing that,
uh,
I'm more now realizing that there's
like just a lot of deep emotional,
weird trauma underneath every,
every accusation of appropriation.
It's not that I think therefore
white girls shouldn't wear braids.
It's that I think I understand more
where the person that is upset is coming
from it. Just from a compassionate
perspective. You didn't know. I get that.
I get that. It just logically it
doesn't, it's not about logic.
Yeah.
But it should be all human interaction
should have some base in logic if you're
going to communicate with things.
I don't agree because emotions
aren't about logic, right?
But should anybody be subject
to your own emotions? Like Shit.
Like you change your behavior,
your dress.
If you're a person who's
completely not racist,
but you enjoy the way your hair looks,
if it's in braids,
should you take into consideration all
the people that you're gonna run into and
they're going to be
upset at you over braids,
even though they're ignorant about
the history of braids and cornrows,
should you alter or change your behavior?
Should you accept the fact that you're
just going to have a certain amount of
cultural appropriation?
Well, let me ask you this, like if you,
I don't have an answer to that question.
I don't,
that is an important part of this.
I mean,
if you're going to accept the fact
that there's some sort of an emotional
attachment to these things,
and that's where the argument comes from,
shouldn't you decide or at least
contemplate whether or not that emotion is
valid?
It doesn't seem to be,
seems to be this real examples
of racism and horrible things.
Like if you want to,
you know,
make your eyes squinty and look like
a Japanese character from a bugs bunny
cartoon in,
you know,
1940 and then you want to go to a
party and people think you're a racist,
you should,
you should be
aware that you're presenting an image
that is inherently racist. Like that's,
that's something that's kind of fucked up.
And you should be considerate about the
way people's emotions are going to fire
up looking at your image.
That's what I'm saying. Yeah,
but that's a different thing than braids.
Oh, but oh, but that's what I'm, I,
I'm not advocating, first of
all, I'm not advocating anything.
I'm just saying I've,
I've delved into this topic enough that
I've started to understand where people
are coming from when they,
when they get activated by send too.
But I think a big part of it is
reinforcement in the community that that's
acceptable to be upset at people for
corn rows or braids. And I don't,
I actually don't disagree with you.
I think you're right about that.
And yet I think it also is connected
to like a legitimate emotional reality
that's happening. Like for example, by
the way, logic is, is very important.
And I would say logic is more
important than emotion when it comes to
communication. But it doesn't
because something is more important,
doesn't negate the, the importance
of the other thing. Well,
it certainly doesn't solve the situation
just by clearly using the logic.
You might get a certain percentage of
the people that agree with you because of
logic, but that's more rare than it is
common, right? It's like, would you,
would you feel comfortable going
to a native American powwow?
You know, with a headdress on, not even
a pilot, there's a powwow next door,
you can see it and you're at a music
festival. Would you wear an Indian head?
I wouldn't, but the reason why you
can't and the reason why you shouldn't,
or the reason why it's an issue is
because the people are marginalized.
Let me take my own people.
I'm Italian and my people,
for the longest time there was a lot of
anti Italian races and my grandfather,
he's talked to me about it,
what it was like coming off the boat,
but then somewhere along the line it
became acceptable for Italians in, in,
in American culture where it's not,
there's no real racism. It doesn't stick.
Like you call it Italian Guinea,
Guinea to our face and we will laugh.
No one cares. You can make meatballs
and Spaghetti all day long.
Nobody gives a shit. Nobody accuses you
of, uh, you know, you have a pizza party.
Nobody thinks it's cultural appropriation,
but try having a TACO party try haven't
Taco Tuesdays people get pissed you. Why?
Because Mexicans still experience
real racism in this country.
Whereas Italians largely just don't.
Right.
And like Taco Tuesdays and example of
something that's like, who fucking cares?
That's not important.
And so if I'm wearing a Sombrero,
exactly offensive to people, if that's as,
that's as deep as most people go. Right.
That's dumb. What are you
talking about at Kennedy to Taco?
I mean that's done and it is dumb,
but if you kind of like get under the Dme,
which is the name of my, my
third out, my third special.
So it's not yet live in Oakland now.
Fucking Hitler and then
get under the dumb.
But if you get under
the first like the most,
the epidermal layer of like
flashy and sanity and go like,
what's really happening here is like,
oh,
it's just what you're saying
actually you're more woke than you,
than you let on June interest. It's like,
it's really about like power dynamics.
It's not really about the
appropriation incident,
although on some level maybe it is.
It's really about the power
dynamic underneath it. Well,
I think one of the things that we're
seeing in universities in particular is
people
that are exercising the ability to affect
change even if it doesn't make sense
because they have the ability to uh,
point out something that they think is
incorrect or is unjust and then they
attack it and go after it and then they
see results. And by seeing those results,
it's almost in a lot of ways kind
of attached to the same idea.
Like if you're worth x amount of dollars,
why do you still chase money?
Because you're trying to get the
thrill of the accomplishment.
There's the game that's going on and
there's a certain amount of game going on
trying to get that white kid that you
don't even know to cut off his dreads.
Whether or not you know
that the Romans wore dreads,
whether or not you know
that the Greeks wore dreads,
the vikings and all these different
people had them. It doesn't matter.
It's like there's a little tiny white guy
and that girl could yell at that white
guy then chase him with
a pair of scissors.
Yeah, exactly. It's, it's the
incidents are the absurdity, but the,
but the current, the conceptual current
is somewhat valid. I mean, the knee over,
you know, I'm sorry, but to
some degree, like even you,
and I think that you're naturally
skeptical towards concepts like cultural
appropriation because, and I am too,
because as a, especially as Comedians,
it's very easy to see the absurdity. It's
so stupid and it's so, it's a pointless,
like, well, we can't not adopt each
other's cultures. That won't ever happen.
So, but even we'd go, okay,
but I wouldn't wear a
Sombrero to a Mexican club.
I wouldn't walk into a club like, oh, hey,
what's up? Right. So eat. So if you say,
okay, it's almost pornography,
right. I know it when I see it.
I know when I know it's offensive
when I feel it. Right. You know,
so if you kind of expand further and
go, okay, even the absurd examples,
I kind of understood.
I'm going to try to understand from me.
I'm going to try to understand where
people are coming from with that.
Then I can kind of contextualize it.
No, I don't have to agree with it,
but I can at least say, oh, I
get where this is coming from.
It's coming from historical antecedents
of racism and oppression that are
connected to hairstyle
and, and the, and, and uh,
all of these musicians that have taken
black culture and made money off of it.
There's all this like deeper
sedimentary layers of emotionality.
I don't have to heat it and
change accordingly, but I do,
I would be foolish to ignore it.
Right.
Yeah,
that completely makes sense.
And also I get it from a point of view
of a person comes from culture that used
to be maligned and he isn't anymore.
I wanted to make one final
point about that cause I,
I think I figured out how to make
my cultural appropriation point. Uh,
I don't want to take us back too far,
but I think what we're,
what we're doing is like, and we
came to a good place with a dislike.
What we're talking about, it's
all about language, right?
So cultural appropriation, your
immediate reaction is, that's absurd.
And some of the examples
people use is absurd. But the,
the underneath the racism is just,
we're talking about racial insensitivity,
we're talking about being insensitive.
And if you try to just focus on that,
then you can get to like the
reality of what's happening.
And the original point I wanted to make
was in this article I read about it,
it said that we often get
locked on linguistic the, the,
the boat that the concept
floats in on the absurd boat.
So like black lives matter is
the ultimate example you gave.
I just thought this was such a fascinating
point is like black lives matter,
it's the name of the organization
that is there to fight against police
brutality and killing of black kids.
Right?
And people react to the words, right? So
people go, what are you talking about?
Black lives matter. All lives
matter. Blue lives matter.
And basically if you,
you don't acknowledge that it's
black lives matter to that,
which is really obvious,
right?
You're fighting about the
words black lives matter
where we haven't been talking.
You've left the, the foundation
principle behind like a long time ago,
which is police brutality. No one's even
talking about police brutality anymore.
Now they're just talking
about the language that you
chose to call your group.
So at any rate, I think that was
the thing I was trying to say.
No, that makes sense. Look,
all of it makes sense.
If what is going on is people
are being racist, right?
If someone is doing something
for racial inappropriate or, um,
cultural appropriation at the heart
of it involves racial insensitivity or
racist in sensitivity,
but there's, there's difference,
right? Racist, theoretically,
racist is an,
again,
racism is a word that doesn't
have a lot of use anymore either.
Because you described the same phenomenon
of you saying to like your black
friend. Like, wow, I didn't expect it to
be so articulate. You mean well, right.
You mean you were trying to be polite,
right. Or I don't like black people there.
They're bad.
These are the same.
It's the same word to describe
both of those things. Right, right.
So in sensitivity is,
is not overt and aggressive
racism. Yeah. I think,
yeah, yeah, yeah. It's insensitive.
It's insensitive racism.
Like you're not being sensitive to the
possibility that you're saying something
offensive
or just doing something boarish Lee dump.
Now I agree with you.
The logic is more important than that
than that. But I think, you know,
the more aware we can all be
about how to not be a dick. Yeah.
It's like people want
to say, um, you know,
you could never have all
in the family on TV today.
Could you imagine people would go crazy?
Well then that's cause we moved past that.
I mean that's what's going on.
What's going on is there's a process
and one of the things is disturbing to
people about Trump and what's
disturbing to people about this new, um,
freedom to mock Jews or to pointed them
as the root of all evil and that it's
much more open than it's been before,
is it?
We thought we got through that and then
slowly but surely the demonization of
individual groups and in
terms of, you know, like who,
who are the bad guys and
who are the good guys?
And instead having it been boiled
down to activities and behaviors and
individual human beings
that are the problem,
not giant groups of people that
believe in one God versus another God,
which is what it's been historically.
The idea is that as time goes
on and as people like my people,
the Italians become so integrated
that you can't be racist about us anymore.
Right. It doesn't work. Right. Totally.
I mean it really doesn't work. Yeah.
It's one of the best examples of it.
And totally,
it's,
it's fascinating because there's so many
things that are there still and you're
like, they don't have any charge
or power any longer. Not only that,
there's so much gross behavior by
Italian, it just goes unchecked, you know?
And I think the soprano's is probably
responsible for a lot of that.
I was in Italy,
uh,
last year and I was walking home real
late at night and I saw this guy,
he's got his girlfriend up against the
car and he's fucking like going off on
her and I'm like this little
like liberal American boy, like,
is somebody going to call the police?
And then I kind of stood there for a while
longer and he's screaming in her face,
and then I just like look for about
like two or three minutes ago. Oh,
this is just some Italian shit.
I just walked home.
Okay.